hi everybody Jim Cameron here welcome to
sci-fi support we have a question here
from Jack Hayes sci-fi why you got to be
the most pessimistic genre jet packs
don't make up for totalitarianism I
think there's a lot of pessimism in
science fiction about our social systems
but hard to not be pessimistic these
days you know I mean I think that the
apocalyptic nature of science fiction is
always a comment on our on our times and
I'm feeling particularly apocalyptic
right now let's move on to the next one
so official beer a all right what the is
a tractor beam and why does every sci-fi
film have one well I actually haven't
made a sci-fi film yet that has tractor
beam in it but tractor beam is mythical
technology or you can reach out with
some invisible force and grab something
and pull it to you the tractor the
tractor beam is obviously a technology
we don't have but there is this little
thing called coal flux pinning by the
way when you have a type 2
superconductor in a powerful magnetic
field you get this thing called the
Meissner effect which means that you can
actually lock on to it and hold it in
place and manipulate it that's a tractor
beam that in a sense that works over a
very short distance so maybe we'll be
able to figure out a tractor beam tonio
tony of earth that's good
artificial intelligence is not going to
end well have these engineers watched
any of the Terminator movies yeah
actually they do it just doesn't
dissuade them in sort of military
think-tank circles they actually talk
about the Skynet problem doesn't
dissuade them from developing this stuff
as fast as humanly possible you know at
the time the Terminator was made in 1984
the idea of killer drones in the sky was
was pure you know pure science fiction
the next big stage is gonna be when do
we give till authority to an actual
robotic intelligence people are
seriously arguing the ethics of that the
point is even if we were to suddenly
grow a moral conscience here in this
country and decide that it's a bad idea
to develop an artificial general
intelligence somebody else is going to
do it and then the military will will
justify us developing it because if we
don't do what the other guys will do it
so it is gonna happen the people who are
working out the for
front of artificial general intelligence
say it's not if it's when and they're
outside prediction is fifty years and
they're inside prediction is ten to
fifteen years as a civilization it's
been a profoundly alter the nature of
our existence I believe and you know a
better way to think we're doomed
personally okay this is from mellow so
why does every sci-fi show do this whole
Android becoming human trope as opposed
to an Android which looks human not
becoming human somehow that's not as
interesting I guess I think we just
endlessly explore this idea of the human
appearing machine and it's our way of
dealing one with our angst about where
robotics might be going I think
historically it was more about just kind
of playing with these ideas that you
can't trust people that's what it all
boils down to kind of at its core it's
that we've we've got to hunt you know a
hundred thousand years of not trusting
each other
Mikko koala my question how do you think
the popularity of sci-fi in the mid
twentieth century has played a part in
our 21st century obsession with actually
creating real robots that's actually a
really intelligent question I think that
a lot of the 20th century science
fiction about robots I should prepare
has prepared us very well for imagining
society in which robots play a real role
I think we're just kind of drumming our
fingers impatiently waiting for the tech
to get worked out and you know I think
we've all seen the advancements in in
technology I see us now moving into
essentially or already living in a
science fictional world
Wojtek Quba multiple concepts from
science fiction ie tablets Rockets
autonomous drones are now a reality will
we have alien like monsters - I think
science fiction is very interesting in
the way that it predicted some things
highly accurately and didn't predict
other things very well at all now in
terms of will we have alien like
monsters the alien and by the way it's
capitalized so there I think they're
referring to the alien to be very
literal about the answer you'd have to
go out into space too
counter that type of alien some kind of
hostile alien life-form based on some
completely different kind of biology
probably in our lifetimes we're not
going to get much past the orbit of Mars
maybe to the asteroid belt to Jupiter
we're not progressing in terms of human
spaceflight very fast so in terms of us
going out and being in jeopardy from an
alien with a capital A I don't see that
happening very soon I think it's
interesting to point out that we have
not one of the time not one tiny shred
of evidence of actual life beyond the
earth we all would love to see it but we
have no evidence whatsoever mega knocks
why does the sci-fi fantasy film never
win the Oscar
exactly Megan what I'm saying costumes
makeup right it drives me nuts every
year the first time I noticed this was
when I was just a movie fan and not a
practitioner yet when Star Wars which to
me was the ultimate science fiction film
in its day so this would have been 77
probably the Oscars of 78 lost to Annie
Hall a little cute relationship story
and Star Wars like what the are you
people thinking there's this attitude
that that science fiction is not
humanistic enough that it's not it's not
about real people but there also is
science fiction that plays by the rules
of good drama and is important
conceptually and says something about
our society and has great characters and
is well made and so on the Academy just
has a blind spot about it so they
typically will award you know technical
awards but not the real stuff not the
acting people seem to think that you
can't do a humanistic movie if you're
standing in front of a green screen
which is not true at all all movie is
artifice you know you're you're
recording only a kid got a script it's
all written down and you're you're doing
take after take after take after take
and cutting it all together so it's in
it's innately artificial the truth
underlies the the artifice the truth of
what you're saying is the direct
connection with the with the audience
science fiction can do that as well as
as any other genre in filmmaking and so
I think this is an oversight
okay time-travel movies always seem to
make no sense terminators still confuse
me how can Kyle Reese be John Connors
father if he has to t travel well you
have what's called classically in
science fiction the grandfather paradox
it basically says if you build a time
machine and you go back to your time and
you kill your grandfather before he's
met your grandmother you'll cease to
exist and therefore you've never built
the time machine so therefore you you
didn't go back and kill him so therefore
you do exist you wind up with these
endlessly recursive causal loops in time
travel no science fiction author has
ever resolved this and in fact most
physicists will tell you that time
travel certainly into the past and
altering our present is impossible but
that's no fun that's no fun so we're
doing time travel so just shut up that's
my answer to that one but if you want to
get technical about it I would say the
time-travel works like quantum
superposition so you have a number of
hypothetical futures but until the whole
thing plays itself out it hasn't
collapsed down to that future which
actually persists and prevails and goes
on from there and all the other futures
that might have been possible even if
people thought they were alive in them
simply cease to exist okay guys thanks
for geeking out with me and I hope you
got your daily dose of science fiction